i wanted to train for it and there were
some ballet sequences that that um
we wanted to have the option to to
incorporate into the movie so i trained
forever and i have two left feet i'm the
most klutzy person in the world and i
have no
um what do you call grace
the night before this was filmed amber
heard claims she was headbutted by
johnny depp
and i've got these dances down
technically perfectly i'm learning all
the movements
but the last thing we get to are the
hands the actress appeared on james
corden's the late late show covered in
makeup
she said it hid the extent of her
injuries including black eyes
a busted nose and a split lip
underneath it all ms heard says with
these injuries
it was suggested in court she'd played
around with the images
she said she wouldn't know how to
speaking at the high court amber heard
said the incident in december 2015
was one of the worst and most violent
nights of her relationship with mr depp
and denied her claims were complete lies
[Music]
johnny depp suing the publishers of the
sun newspaper over an article describing
him as a wife-beater
allegations he strenuously denies
his ex-wife told the court she had not
stubbed a cigarette
out on his cheek claiming mr depp
self-harmed
his body's full of scars she said it
happened as part of as amber heard
described it a three-day hostage
situation
during which mr depp had thrown bottles
at her like grenades
she was accused of being extremely
violent to johnny depp
to which she replied i only threw things
to escape johnny when he was beating me
up
sometimes that's all i had it was on
this trip there honeymoon on the
oriental express that amber heard
says she was hit and choked by johnny
depp he denies this saying
throughout their relationship he'd been
the victim of domestic abuse
with these photos taken after his
ex-wife attacked him
amber heard will be back to give
evidence on thursday with her ex-husband
looking on
as one of the most high-profile libel
trials of the past decade
nears its conclusion adele robinson sky
news at the high court